um we had another yesterday
in the uh in the rush to get this first
day
of trump's second impeachment trial um
out live on all of our platforms i did
not cover
the white house press briefing with
press secretary
jen saki and yes i will address my
pronunciation of saki
um in the voicemail segment today and
reporters
just will not stop asking really dumb
questions here is a reporter asking jen
saki does joe biden plan on hanging up a
painting
of donald trump in the white house
of course donald trump not hanging a
painting of obama as is often done of
the prior
president in the midst of everything
that's going on in week three of joe
biden's administration
jen saki asked what about joe biden's
view on a trump
painting in the white house um
president trump former president trump
he broke tradition by not having
his predecessor have a portrait hanged
up here
as far as i'm saying that was something
that was considered totally the normal
thing to do
will president biden be inviting his
predecessor to hang up a portrait
somewhere
and will he get the obamas back in to
finally get their you know their
ceremony
i have no portrait revealings or
portrait plans or portrait events to
preview for you
but i have not been given any indication
that we would break with tradition in
that regard
so not a major issue as you can imagine
i really don't know what's up with some
of these questions it's not completely
clear to me because they're not
necessarily coming from
all from reporters with with bad
reputations or from whom
we would expect this i mean peter ducey
yes
we know what he's trying to do and get
sound bites for right-wing media but
some of these are not reporters that
have particularly
bad reputations or or are known to have
uh
bad intentions but we these these
questions simply will not stop now
here's a bonus clip i mentioned peter
ducey
a peter ducey asking a question this is
just unbelievable
irony is dead peter ducey asked about
conflicts of interest for joe biden you
really can't make this up
uh joe biden's um son-in-law
was advising biden on vaccine response
at some
earlier point here is peter ducey
continuing to try to make a name for
himself with supposedly tough questions
of jen
saki and he brings this up take a listen
quick one on conflicts of interest and
some reporting that's been done
by our colleagues at other networks the
president's son-in-law
dr howard crime was advising candidate
biden
on kobe 19 response while he was
investing
in companies involved with the cloven 19
response through
his company startup health dr crying has
been
at the white house since the
inauguration
is he still advising the president on
copenhagen response
well dr crine is his son-in-law um the
president there are questions about a
potential
well and i think he was here because the
president was inaugurated recently which
is
understandable the president has made
clear that there will be an absolute
wall between him and any businesses
connected with his family members
and as he reiterated just last week no
family member is going to have an office
in the white house or be involved in any
government policy making
that applies to his son-in-law and
applies to every single member of his
family
this guy was there for the inauguration
he's not working for the white house
how can they pretend to care about
conflicts of interest
now we just learned jared and ivanka
in positions not confirmed by the senate
nor
elected by the people were working in
the white house
and made between 200 and 600 million
dollars
while working at the white house for
those four years
now sadly we expected this and
unfortunately it does work on a lot of
people
millions of trump supporters who never
cared about conflicts of interest for
the last four years
will fixate on this stuff and in that
sense it's not stupid for fox news to do
it
for their audience they look like
complete fools to most of the world
and the country but for much of their
audience
this is how they generate narratives and
create agendas
but what about what about this what
about this vaccine advice
where were you when devanka was making
millions from
handbags and working for trump and
kellyanne conway was promoting the
handbags on fox news
where were you then well they were
nowhere because they didn't care and
it's not about principle it's merely
about what can we say
to try to attack joe biden and
unfortunately for the low information
fox news audience the oan types the news
max types
this may well be compelling and it's how
you generate narrative
most healthy granola bars have sort of a
bad reputation they don't taste good
they don't fill you up they don't really
satisfy your craving
but our sponsor monk pack has changed
granola bars monk pack keto granola bars
are sweet and delicious
soft and chewy with only 140 calories
1 gram of sugar 2 net carbs which makes
them work beautifully
for the keto or low carb lifestyles
they come in flavors like coconut cocoa
chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla my
new favorite
i love these because i can grab one
anytime
it's quick it's a great snack forget the
dry
bland granola bars try monk pack
keto granola bars if you don't love them
like i do
they'll give you all of your money back
you'll get 20
off when you go to monkpack.com and use
the coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video